[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'agent secondaires donc on a été
lauréat avec social agence beaucoup sts
du projet de résidences étudiantes à
barkin réversible public à palaiseau sur
le plateau de saclay s'agit d'une
résidence étudiante 292 chambres de
sensibiliser de logements est associé un
parking parkings publics qu'ils n'ont la
demande était d'être réversible
donc il s'agit d'un programme hybride
mixte qui couple ces deux entités
programmatique
la particularité de ce projet c'est
vraiment leur imbrication programmatique
donc une implication horizontale avec
une partie du parking en superstructure
sur deux niveaux et au dessus les
logements étudiants qui viennent au
dessus de ceux par qui
l'organisation elle est assez simple
avec un grand rez-de-chaussée plutôt
très ouvert très libre qui laisse passer
les bus qui accueille finalement tous
les espaces collectifs ou à chacun des
programmes donc des salles de travail
des espaces de services pour la
résidence l'accueil de la résidence
également
des commerces et également tous les
espaces d'accueil pour le parking une
des questions qui étaient importantes
c'était la question de la réversibilité
de ce projet dont comment anticiper le
futur avec la question du parking la
question des stationnements de la
voiture donc comment faire finalement
ces équipements un peu de la modernité
qui sont souvent cachés en faire un lieu
qui soit agréable ou en tout cas qu'on
puisse repenser sa fonctionnalité
dans un futur proche ou lointain
notamment avec l'arrivée du futur métro
sur le plateau le précaire d'argent 2020
je pense qu'il nous a été remis du fait
de cette hybridité programmatique
il est assez riche en fait de faire des
bâtiments qu'ils soient hybrides que des
bâtiments peut-être uniquement de
logement peuvent être enrichis d'un
autre programme et c'est ce que montre
cette opération et je pense que les
caire nous a récompensés pour ça c'était
gratifiant pour l'ensemble de nos
partenaires techniques a également pour
nos deux maîtres d'ouvragé mille et une
vies habitat pour la résidence étudiante
et le pps pour le parking public
réversible
[Musique]
à